Bobby, Will,
congratulations, you
guys are in the third and final
round of this competition.
When you came here, you
tore down our Great Wall
to make your signature
blades that have propelled
you into this third round.
And now, it's time
for a little payback
as we send you back
to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
You ready to see what it is?
Yes, sir.
Yes. sir.
All right, that weapon is--
[intense music]
--the Chinese war sword.
Ooh.
[blade clanking]
All right, gents.
Do your best work.
We'll see you in four days.
Thank you, sir.
Good luck.
Good luck to you, too.
[rock music]
It's day one, back in
Hodgenville at the home forge.
I've got a Chinese
war sword to make.
This thing is huge.
All my forging is
done by hand, so it's
going to be a challenge.
I'm starting off with a
piece of 51-60 Spring steel,
and I've got a lot
of metal to move.
That's going to take a minute.
Normally, I like to
forge the tang first,
so I'm going to
lay on my shoulders
and start getting my tang
drawn out to its final length.
I'm working my way up the blade,
and the hammer head falls off.
Luckily, I've got
plenty of hammers,
so I knock a handle off
and put a old cross pein
head on this one.
And the second
cross pein's broken.
And all I have is a 6
and 1/2 pound sledge.
So "Forged in Fire" stars,
that's when the hammers
start falling apart.
Right now, I'm really missing
the press in the judges' forge.
There is an
extremely long list
of things to get done today.
A quench would just be a
blessing all the way around.
Let's get cracking.
One of the iconic
features of this sword
is it has a hole up on
the pierced clip point
that you always take the
chance of creating a crack
when you're drilling
that close to the edge.
That made it a
whole lot lighter.
Now, it's time to
do the heat treat.
I fill up my quench tube
with fresh quench oil.
I got my blade heated up.
I get my blade.
That can go straight
into the jig.
I've got a fully quenched
Chinese war sword.
Oh!
Thank you, lord.
I wanna let it
temper tonight, and
tomorrow, I'm ready to
start on the handle,
and keep moving forward.
I've got a lot of work to do.
First thing I've
got to do today is
start drawing out this blade.
It's nowhere near
the parameters,
but I did repair my
cross pein hammer,
so hopefully, that holds up.
Right now, I'm drawing out
at about an inch an hour.
I've got, like, 20
minutes left today.
And--
Oh, [bleep].
--a huge crack has opened
up behind my ricasso.
That's not good.
I have developed a major
crack right at the most
vulnerable point in my handle.
My gut reaction is
to jump on the welder
and seal up this
crack the best I can.
But I might be able to think
of a better way to repair this,
so I'm going to just stop and
try to come at this problem
again tomorrow.
This crack is just going to
be over my head all night.
It's the morning of day four.
Now, I'm ready to start
putting an edge on this blade.
This is an extremely long
blade, so it's going to be
a challenge to sharpen this.
I got an edge put on it.
I want to test my edge
geometry and see if it's
the edge I'm looking for.
So we're going to try just a
simple gallon jug slice here.
I get a good, smooth, clean cut.
There's no issues, no problems.
Good deal.
The leather wrap
is the way to go.
I don't want this handle to have
any chance of coming undone.
I am gluing this
one wrap at a time.
It actually looks pretty good.
I'm done.
A little bit nervous.
I'd be lying if I said I wasn't.
But the excitement is much
more than anything else.
[rock music]
It's day four.
I'm going to have to MIG
weld this crack to keep
it from getting any worse.
Then I'm going to create a
mechanically connected san mai.
I'm gonna take two
pieces of mild steel,
and weld them and rivet
them onto the sides
to create a new handle.
They're going to be my guards.
They're going to be my pommel.
And they're going to
make sure my blade
doesn't break into two pieces.
With the remaining
time left, I've gotta
get started making this handle.
I slap these handles on.
They're gluing up.
Whoo!
This has been the longest and
shortest four days of my life.
I wish I had more time
to focus on the details.
But at the end of the day, it
meets parameters, it's safe,
and it functions.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your
Chinese war sword
and deliver one strike
on this ram carcass.
Let's see how deadly they are.
Bobby, you're first.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
My heart's just
bouncing out of my chest.
You've got the skin.
You've got the bones.
You've got the hide.
I only get one shot
at this ram carcass?
[rock music]
All right, Bobby.
One and done.
As much as this is very
intimidating in its look,
it is crafted nicely.
It's got a beautiful
look to its finish.
The balance, it's just right
for a two-handed sword.
A little forward-heavy,
but that tells
you that's where the power is.
Your edge is sharp.
Even cutting through the
spine and bones, no issues,
no glinting, and no rolls.
Overall, sir, your Chinese
war sword will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Will, your turn.
Ready?
- Yes, sir.
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Doug picks up my weapon.
And at this point, all the
nerves are out the window.
I'm just excited.
He's walking towards
this ram's carcass,
and I'm ready to see
it fly right through.
[exhales]
[music playing]
(WHISPERING) Good job, buddy.
Thank you.
[music playing]
All right, Will.
Let's talk about your
Chinese war sword here.
First up, it's a
very bulky handle.
It's rounded.
So as you get a good grip on
it, you can feel it starts
to spread my hands around.
But the wrapping that
you put around it does
allow me to get a good grip
on it, so good on that.
And one shot, one kill.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Oh, I just felt a
frightening chill.
Must be the strength test.
J?
You boys remember me.
Yes, sir.
Welcome to the ice block chop.
This is going to test not only
your edge in your heat treat,
but the overall
construction of your swords.
Now, what your
blades do to the ice,
I'm not too concerned about.
I want to see what the ice
is gonna do to your blades.
Bobby, you're up first.
How are you feeling?
Ready to go.
Me too.
Let's do it.
[intense music]
This is not just an ice block.
This thing's a glacier.
J can't wait to start
swinging that thing.
He's going to do it with
everything he has in him.
I just don't know how
it's going to hold up.
[rock music]
[grunting]
Great job, Bobby.
Still razor sharp.
No rolls, no glints, nothing.
Everything's still tight.
I mean, one of the swings, I
was able to split that block.
So it's got a good feel.
Just nice job overall.
Thank you.
OK, Will, how are you feeling?
[laughs] I'm nervous,
but I'm excited.
OK.
I'm just excited, so--
[music playing]
This is going to be brutal.
I'm really worried about the
crack in my tang right now.
Chopping through a block
that big is so tough.
If there are any
compromises in my blade,
this is where they're
going to show their head.
[exhales]
[grunts]
[clanging]
[music playing]
Well, we got a problem, Will.
A big problem, sir.
Right where you did your
very rough hollow grind,
there's a couple dark
spots right in here.
And with that thin
spot right there,
it was enough to allow that
blade to just snap right
in half on the first swing.
So it did not survive,
but good effort.
Thank you, sir.
Well, Will, sometimes
this competition's
full of tough breaks,
and you've had one
on the first strike against this
ice block in our strength test.
Unfortunately, we cannot
continue testing your blade
against your opponent's.
And for that reason, I'd like to
invite you to shake our hands,
shake your opponent's
hand, and then please
leave the forge to your right.
Come on, my friend.
Yes, sir.
Excellent work, dude.
Thank you, brother.
It's tough.
Having a blade break is
obviously-- you know,
it's a tremendous failure.
But at the end of the day,
I did the best I could
with the tools I had.
And I'm still proud of the
piece that I put forward.
This competition has
given me the inspiration
to move forward and
challenge myself in new ways.
Bobby, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
And that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
[applause]
Come on forward, my friend.
Great job.
Great work.
Thank you.
I feel on top of
the world right now.
That's a great piece, man.
That was fun to swing.
This is not just a win for me.
This is a win for my family,
my friends, the other smiths
that I teach in the forge.
This goes a long ways
for our whole community.
[music playing]